el brutal asesinato de esta mujer de 31
años madre de tres hijos conmoción o a
la nación y llego a simbolizar los
errores sistemáticos de Francia en la
lucha contra la violencia de género en
mayo child out recibió múltiples
disparos de su marido del que estaba
separada antes de ser quemada viva en la
calle ahora si se agentes de la zona de
Burdeos incluido el jefe de la Policía
Local se enfrentan a medidas
disciplinarias por una serie de fallos y
negligencias en el caso el exmarido de
edad y había sido condenado por
violencia de género pero nunca fue
señalado al salir de la cárcel bajo
libertad condicional agredió a su ex
mujer pero si yo libre la víctima
presento una denuncia temiendo por su
vida pero no se inició ninguna
investigación 2 meses después fue
asesinada
ciencia del sistema y sus causas para
que en el futuro no vuelvan a producirse
el caso fue uno más de los 113
asesinatos de mujeres a manos de sus
parejas en 2021 según un recuento de la
Asociación en ut francia es uno de los
países con mayor numero de feminicidios
de Europa al respecto el Gobierno ha
introducido nuevas medidas como el uso
de brazaletes electrónicos y el
despliegue de agentes especialmente
formados para hacer frente a la
violencia de género pero las
organizaciones dicen que no es
suficiente en lo que va de año tres
mujeres y han sido asesinadas por sus ex
parejas